(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] With IBM
Robotic Process Automation,
you can build bots that work
with us, not just for us.
Your business needs to find and capitalize
on more opportunities
to improve accessibility
and interactivity with automation,
and that transformation
begins by improving
not just what our bots can do,
but how we interact with them.
IBM Robotic Process
Automation lets you build
and expose native chatbots
in just a few commands.
Automating day-to-day
tasks across your business
on a streamlined AI-powered interface
in a low-code, easy
access studio environment
your teams can use, even
if they aren't developers.
Now, your bots can help your
teams save time and money
while freeing up talented
workers to dedicate their skills
to more sophisticated activities.
It's time to look inward and
find a way to boost performance
across your enterprise.
Think of IBM RPA as your
automation accelerator.
You can write the script
for smarter customer experiences today.
(dramatic music)